les mêmes règles pour tous à la veille
de cette rentrée des classes avec le
variant omicron en toile de fond le
ministre de la santé a précisé dans un
entretien au jdd que les restrictions
qui s'appliquent désormais aux enfants
sont les mêmes que pour l'ensemble de la
population
les élèves positif devront donc observer
sept jours d'isolement afin jeu sid
éviter de fermer massivement des classes
olivier vers ans qui a aussi précisé le
protocole pour les cas contactez le
recours pour les autres élèves
potentiellement contact sera trois tests
consécutifs permettant de venir à
l'école tant que ces derniers sont
négatifs l'exécutif a fait le choix de
ne pas reporter la rentrée des classes
et ce malgré l'inquiétude des
enseignants les écoles vous d'être
ouverte mais surtout ouverte au virus
dans les semaines à venir le syndicat
déplore l'absence de prise en compte du
variant omicron et plus généralement des
règles insuffisantes notamment en ce qui
concerne les distances entre les élèves
dans les cantines ou encore le monde de
masques ffp2 il s'inquiète aussi du fait
de devoir gérer simultanément des
enfants dans les établissements tandis
que d'autres devront suivre les cours à
distance c'est là où on n'est pas
d'accord avec le ministère on ne peut
pas se dédoubler on ne pourra pas
assurer les deux présentiel et distant
ciel les enfants à la fois en maternelle
et en élémentaire ne peuvent pas être
autonome à la veille des vacances
scolaires plus de 3100 classes étaient
fermés dans l'hexagone en raison de
l'épidémie pour anticiper les problèmes
de garde qui risque de se poser dans les
semaines à venir le gouvernement a
autorisé par décret les assistantes
maternelles à accueillir six enfants au
lieu de quatre habituellement